[Musique]
ethan parfois les apparences sont
trompeuses
il faudra que tu regardes bien outre la
te projeter beaucoup plus loin ça va
être douloureux ne m'en veut pas aller
tan ça t'aidera accomplir son destin
l'été c'est ne cesse de croître en
raison des rejets biophysique de
l'oxygène artificielle appelée plus
communément le mal du siècle
l'année dernière j'avais vingt gamins
dans ma classe cette année j'en ai tous
et and white
vous savez ce que votre père a failli si
je vous présente le chronicle si je vous
disais que vous avez la possibilité de
tous nous sauver
sauvez votre femme nous avons reçu un
message qui venait du futur du futur
c'est une machine à voyager dans le
temps
ceux qui ont envoyé ce message ont dû
trouver un remède tu crois vraiment que
je vais sauver le monde
ton père y croyait vous êtes peut-être
la seule chance qu'il reste à l'humanité
de trouver un vaccin 9,8
ça
ouah
étape 2 reviendra
nous devons trouver ceux qui ont envoyé
ce message nous sommes au commencement
d'un voyage qui pourrait tout changer
il faut que je me fasse confiance il ne
s'agit plus de trouver un remède il ya
certainement quelque chose qui me
faisait ça imagine que nous sommes tous
physiquement relié à l'univers il ya un
champ invisible qui nous lie les uns aux
autres toi moi les étoiles nous pouvons
rien sans ses petits doigts se passer se
passa ya pas d'autres moyens
nous sommes tous connectés à travers le
temps il s'agit pas de sauver le mandat